we are all just collins able aren't we
new to town just trying to figure out
how this place works
just trying to lend a hand trying to
figure out what happened how we can
solve this case
and hey teamwork makes the dream work
right hey guys pete here this is my
mayor of east town episode 2
breakdown pretty exciting to see that
this series can shift gears like this
i loved all the character development in
the first episode
and they really took that and ran with
the mystery in this installment
real quick a spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the episode yet
this video won't be for you do come back
after you've seen it but it is your time
to leave and with that out of the way
let's get into it episode 2 was titled
fathers and they're
everywhere fathers as parents of this
town where everyone is connected in one
way or another
and also a conspicuously shady father
at the church almost feels a little too
shady you might say
and i think there's enough of that to go
around in this episode
everyone seems like a suspect and
everyone they really put out there as
being a suspect
feels kind of like a red herring it's
also the tale of two mares
we get to know more about her personal
background and we get to see her in
action at work
where on the one hand she's super
competent and then
on the other we see that she plays
pretty fast and loose
and really takes things too far when she
ignores brianna's request for a lawyer
in the competent category when she
arrives on the crime scene
she immediately takes charge she touches
the body she realizes that the girl's
been there for a while
when the chief asks her about the wound
she feels confident in saying that her
killer would have been face to face with
her
and we see her experience when she goes
to tell aaron's father about what
happened
knowing it's going to be a tough
situation she makes a call to laurie her
childhood best friend
who happens to be married to one of
kenny's cousins and she has him and
another cousin come to offer support
this goes about how you would expect and
i have to say that it was a great
portrayal of a father's grief by the
actor who plays aaron's father
he does point the finger directly at
dylan saying that he never wanted her to
have the baby that he hated her for it
and that he's the only person that would
want to hurt her there were a couple of
interesting things that might be
clues here first he was sleeping in the
chair when they came to the door
that might be normal but we do have to
remember that there was that shot of him
at the end of the last episode coming
inside after dawn
also whenever she asked him if he was
there all night he says that he was
and then there was this weird shot of
billy the other cousin looking at him
after she asked which just felt kind of
out of place
when she interviews him dylan doesn't
give anything away he's actually very
unhelpful he's just looking out for
himself he legitimately seems to have no
interest
in helping mare figure out who might
have killed the mother of his child
he also says he didn't talk to aaron the
night before which may be
true but they definitely had an
interaction that was worth mentioning
and things break down in the interview
when mare uses that one thing that she
found when she looked around in aaron's
room
the pamphlet for the ear surgery drops
that on dylan
as a way to imply that he may have had a
motive to kill her
after that he leaves there's a press
conference where she explains to the
community what happened
dawn and some other people are there and
the sentiment is that they want to find
out what happened to katie
and they want to know if these two
crimes are connected when mayor returns
to her office she meets
colin zabel the county detective sent in
to help out
we don't know much about him at this
point he did solve a cold case
of a ten-year-old girl and for all
intents and purposes
he seems like a pretty good compliment
to what we know about mayor
of course she's pretty cold to him she
doesn't like the fact that he's there in
the first place
but we do see them sort of working
together after a video surfaces of the
fight in the woods
mayor sets things in motion to get an
assault warrant for brianna
but she's also distracted because she
wants to figure out why siobhan was
there and why she didn't tell her about
it
she's on the way to the family
restaurant and she almost leaves colin
behind
he doesn't appear to take it personally
he just wants to know where they need to
go
if they're not carpooling together here
we see him
advocating for possibly taking things
outside not making a scene
and mayor deciding instead to lean into
it she wants to make this a public
arrest
that's going to come back and be a pain
for her because now brianna's father
tony is going to follow mare around for
the rest of the episode
trying to first convince her then
threaten her to let his daughter go
that whole side story wasn't my favorite
part of the episode but i did like the
idea here that
even though what he's doing here is
clearly out of bounds and he escalates
and
eventually he actually throws the gallon
of milk through her window breaking her
window
she doesn't really pay him that much
mind it's sort of like yeah that's just
tony that's how he is and it kind of
underlines that whole idea of how
being a detective in this town where you
know everybody
has its own complications so as i
mentioned in the interview she does take
things too far
brianna doesn't want to talk she asks
for a lawyer it's her right
the interview should end colin doesn't
even know what to do he can't believe
she's still talking
and eventually he does step in and that
opens the door for brianna to drop the
bomb
on her way out she says no wonder your
son [ __ ] killed himself
so we found out that drew's father kevin
who we saw in a vision at the end of the
last episode
took his own life and what's more when
mayor gets back home
she finds out that drew is doing this
thing with his eyes he has a tick
and that makes her worry that he might
have some of the same problems that his
father had
that leads her to go pay a visit to her
ex-husband frank
and there's a plan made so that she'll
go to see the doctor in the morning
but on the way out he asks her about
aaron's case
and we learned that he was a teacher of
hers in school and he plays off
knowing her to the most part he said
they didn't really talk
he even goes as far as saying that he
thought she had problems at home
which in a way kind of points the finger
at her father right
in a murder mystery you know it's the
kind of thing that stands out
it also echoes what the new priest who
was speaking at the church
told her cousin the priest we met in the
first episode
when he asked him about aaron after the
service
he said yeah she was in our youth group
i didn't really know her
we didn't really talk and it all feels
like it may be significant
the next morning we do see her go and
see the doctor she lays out her concern
which the doctor doesn't seem that
worried about she says that it's a
pretty normal thing that happens for
kids his age
but they do decide to have him checked
out by a neurologist just in case
she also asks mayor if she's seeing
someone for therapy
and you know it sounds like a good idea
the more we learn
the more we know she has going on but
she seems pretty dead set against it
what i thought was most interesting
about this exchange was her reaction
when she asked about the
diagnosis she threw out a lot of
different ones that they ran
into when they were trying to get him
help but she never actually settles on
one or even gives an idea of what she
thinks was going on
in context of the story it sounds like
another mystery that she's never been
able to solve
as the case continues we do see colin
and mayor interview all the kids who are
out in the woods
they get an idea of what was happening
out there but no real clues as far as i
could tell that point to anybody being
a suspect colin does interview siobhan
by himself
it's pretty clear that she feels guilty
about what happened
having been the last person to talk to
her but there's also a telling moment
here when she asks about working with
her mom and he asks for advice
and she says to lower your expectations
and this is something that i'll come
back to in a little bit
merrick gets some flowers from richard
and that prompts her to give him a call
it doesn't seem like she has much
interest in seeing him but the
conversation takes a turn when he asks
her about the case
she decides to go with him to an event
there's a pretty funny setup where she's
getting ready
and the whole thing is kind of hilarious
when she's actually there
but he's distracted he actually has a
lot of women that are paying attention
to him
which maybe that's going to be important
one way or the other she gets bored
she's definitely not liking the hors
d'oeuvres and she starts to leave but he
is able to get her to come back inside
after she tells him that he's not
getting laid tonight
at around the same time aaron's dad
kenny slips out of the house
his cousin billy who was babysitting
falls asleep on the couch and he gets a
chance to leave
next time we see him he's in the back of
dylan's car
nursing a bottle of liquor and holding a
gun
he tells him to drive off into the woods
dylan doesn't really have any
choice and when they get to where
they're going he shoots him twice in the
back as he's trying to run away
this feels like a murder but we're left
with a cliffhanger where we don't
actually know how things
ended up after the date mayor does head
home
that's where she has her run in with
tony and that leads to the gown of milk
being thrown through her front window
dawn works at the store and ends up
standing up for her
when she sees what tony's up to and at
the end of the day he seems like he's
gonna continue to be a pain in the ass
it's pretty clear that while everything
else is going on
in the investigation this situation with
drew and the backstory of what happened
to his father
is weighing heavily on her mind and this
situation gets a lot more
complicated because earlier in the
episode helen siobhan and frank
went to visit drew's mother carrie for a
supervised visit
we learned that she's in recovery she's
doing pretty good at this point she's
living in a sober house
and we see that she gets along pretty
well with the rest of the family
although it's very clear that she
doesn't get along with mare
this is underlined in a couple of
different ways here and the big thing
is that she tells the rest of the family
that she's filing paperwork to try to
get full custody
and we do see mayor get an idea about
this later when she looks at the mail
just before the flying bottle of milk
comes through her window
so there were two big cliffhangers here
the first was dylan getting shot
and the second comes when aaron's best
friend jess who we saw her
talking to at her apartment before she
went to the woods
tells her mother that she has a big
secret that she's been keeping
they go over to laurie's house which i'm
not 100
sure why they went there all we know
about laurie is that she's mayor's
friend so when she asks why they didn't
go to the police
i assume it's because mayor is frank's
ex-wife
but i don't understand why that means
that you would go to lori's
i'm not sure if i missed something here
so let me know if you have an idea about
this
in the comments but for the bottom line
the secret was that
dylan isn't the real father of dj
aaron's son
aaron never told her friend jess who it
actually was
but she suspects that it was frank
sheehan
mare's ex-husband this guy that
everybody seems to love
more or less and who also said that he
barely ever talked to aaron
it's a big cliffhanger that's clearly
there to make frank a suspect in the
murder
but if you think about it even just for
a short period of time
everybody likes frank we see that
siobhan likes frank
we see that helen and the rest of the
family like frank everyone else in town
was going over to his place for a party
so if this is true that he is the father
of aaron's child and
other people knew about it or if aaron
was about to expose it
then that would make a lot of other
people potential suspects if they were
trying to cover it up
the episode does end there and it was a
big one there's a lot of stuff that
happened here
some real twists and turns it seems like
this custody battle is gonna be a big
deal for mayor
if she feels like she's responsible in
some way for what happened to kevin then
it tracks that she'll be really
protective of drew
and the fact that his mother's an addict
doesn't inspire a lot of confidence for
someone in that situation
i said i would come back to this idea
about siobhan because
after two episodes it seems like they
get along
okay but there's definitely underlying
tension
and i wonder if that's related to frank
or if it's related to kevin
obviously she loves her father and it
seems pretty likely that she would have
loved her brother in the same way
so problems in east town and problems at
home this episode definitely got me
hooked into the mystery side of things
i was already there for the character
stuff in the first episode and this was
a nice one-two punch
it really almost feels like there's two
different shows side by side here
and i find myself equally invested at
this point
the performances were great across the
board again this week
i liked the introduction of the new
county detective
introducing drew's mom carrie also stirs
the pot so
a lot of interesting new stuff i thought
the cliffhangers were pretty good
a pretty crazy move by kenny to go after
dylan like that
and the whole thing with frank i mean
there's a lot of possibilities that
could come from that
i thought it was notable that we didn't
spend much time at the crime scene
and that it didn't give much away we
don't linger there very long
she was half naked which makes it feel
like she'd probably been sexually
assaulted but there doesn't seem to be
any evidence nearby
and that includes no sighting of her
bike which was one of the few things
that sounded important
when the kids were being interviewed the
one kid said that he saw her bike when
he arrived
but he didn't see it by the time he left
that makes it seem like she rode that
out of there but the last time we saw
her she was just walking into the woods
so there's still not a lot to go off of
there and i think overall this is a good
place to leave things
hopefully next week we'll be able to
really start speculating based on
everyone that we know
in the meantime let's do that in the
comments anyways let me know what you're
thinking what your first
impressions are and where you think this
thing's going
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon